with lizzo being at the center of the
body positive body positivity discussion
we should probably look at her stamina a
b we should say that is she leading with
her weight or does she just exist as a
fat person because I would say Adele did
not lead with her weight nobody really
commented on Adele's weight weight and
Adele's weight because she did not lead
with that she led with her Talent if you
looked at her Instagram it was her in
long beautiful dresses singing no one
really talked about it until she lost
weight on the other hand lizzo if you
look at her Instagram it damn near looks
like corn like it's her thong bikini she
wore a thong bikini thing to to a
basketball game with kids at it yeah in
the name of body positivity sometimes
that's what we mean okay that's Kelly
Clarkson right I think people people may
have commented on it because she did
gain a lot of weight he people will
comment but it's not the main topic of
discussion Kelly Clarkson Clarkson
Because she leads with her Talent